the handshake has always been a peaceful
greeting because with an empty hand you
can't hold a weapon and some researchers
speculate that the up-and-down motion
was meant to shake out hidden weapons in
a study researchers found that people
who shake hands are more likely to raise
their hands to their faces after often
sniffing their own hands leading them to
speculate that we are searching for
social chemical signals on our hands
this gesture hasn't always met peace
according to folklore this sign started
in the 1400s at the Battle of Agincourt
whenever the French captured a British
Archer they would cut two of the fingers
needed to draw a bowstring from their
hand to taught those who had their
fingers cut off other archers would
raise two fingers to the sky Winston
Churchill popularized the sign to mean
victory during World War two for much of
the 20th century this gesture met few in
Britain but on a positive note the Spice
Girls
used it as a symbol for girl power some
speculate that fist bumping comes from
boxing where opponents kiss gloves
before the match in the 70s popular
Baltimore bullets guard Fred Carter was
known for knuckle bumping though even he
points out the gesture predates him some
speculate that it's because of
germaphobes who disliked the direct
contact of handshakes
either way it's as American as apple pie
in 2008 44th President Barack Obama
fist-bump First Lady Michelle Obama on
the campaign trail which at the time was
a very controversial thing for a
president to do a fist bump a pound a
terrorist fist jab so controversial the
first documented high-five was in 1977
during a game between the Los Angeles
Dodgers and Houston Astros Dusty Baker
hit a home run and his teammate Glenn
Burke rushed towards him with his hand
in the air Baker didn't know what to do
so he slapped it because of Dusty Baker
and Glen Burke
the Dodgers considered the high-five
their signature salute Burke is
described as an incredibly charismatic
person he was the first major league
player to come out as gay after his
retirement in 1982 clapping is a
socially driven learned behavior simply
put you're more likely to do it if
others
when primates clap hands in the wild is
because they're scared or just
discovered food and for some reason in
third century BC Rome they instructed
the audience to provide applause at the
end of place according to researchers we
only have 19 different types of smiles
and only six are used for happiness
there's even a miserable smile meant to
convey in a socially acceptable way that
you are sad or in emotional pain and if
study monitoring over 1,000 laugh
episodes only 20% of laughter could be
attributed to something funny most of
the time people laughed during natural
pauses in conversation meaning that
laughter is a form of communication and
not just a reflex did you know any of
these facts already or have you learned
something new
[Music]